♪ ♪
>> Greg: WHILE THE MEDIA HOPES
TO UNSEAT A PRESIDENT, HERE'S
WHAT'S ACTUALLY HAPPENING AROUND
THE WORLD.
CHINESE PRESIDENT XI JINPING
ANNOUNCED HIS COUNTRY WOULD
SIGNIFICANTLY LOWER TARIFFS ON
VEHICLE IMPORTS.
MAYBE HE IS RESPONDING TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S COMPLAINTS
OVER UNFAIR TRADE PRACTICES.
IT'S A SIGNAL TOWARD A
COMPROMISE AFTER TRUMP MADE A
HUGE STINK ABOUT IT.
WHAT'S NEXT?
A SIGH OF RELIEF WHICH SOUNDS
FAMILIAR, MONTHS AGO THE MEDIA
CLAIMED NUCLEAR WAR WITH
NORTH KOREA WAS CERTAIN.
THEN THAT CHAOS GAVE WAY TO
CALM.
REMEMBER THE NOISE BEFORE THE
TAX CUTS?
IT EVAPORATED AS BONUSES FLOWED.
PEOPLE SCREAMED ABOUT THE
APOCALYPSE AFTER WE DITCHED THE
PARIS ACCORD.
WHERE DID THAT FEAR GO?
SAME WITH TPP.
ARE YOU SENSING A PATTERN?
TRUMP KICKS UP THE CONFLICT TO
SET THE TABLE FOR NEGOTIATION
AND YOU END UP WITH PROGRESS.
IT'S OLD SCHOOL.
SO ALL THE REPORTERS UNDER 40
DON'T KNOW WHAT IT IS.
WHERE'S THE PARALYSIS OF
ANALYSIS WE ARE SO USED TO?
CHINA REDUCING TARIFFS.
NORTH KOREA TALKING ABOUT
DENUCLEARIZATION.
ISIS GONE.
FOR NOW, I HOPE.
FOREVER.
WHAT DOES THIS TELL US?
AFTER EIGHT YEARS OF THE
FLOUNDERING AND AFT NEWS SCHOOL,
IT'S A OLD-SCHOOL DUDE IN HIS
70s GETTING THINGS DONE.
MAYBE YOU'VE NEVER SEEN IT IN
YOUR ADULT LIFETIME.
ENJOY IT WHILE IT LASTS.